this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode we're back for part two of
jonathan's look at the weapons of payday
2. uh okay pause there did i just see a
tiny american flag attached to the
optical sight of on this desert eagle if
you want to see more of jonathan's take
on payday 2 make sure to subscribe and
check out our previous episode on the
game's firearms and if there are any
other games guns and mechanics that you
guys want to see jonathan break down let
us know in the comment section below
right let's get back to the guns of
payday 2.
not the most common handgun to be
represented in a game this is the imi or
iwi as they later became jericho pistol
the game has what i believe is the
current version with a polymer frame and
the
decocker on the on the frame now this is
actually called the baby eagle i believe
in the game and that is that's true
because magnum research also sell the
same design having originally worked on
it with um iwi imi and back in the day
as the baby
eagle that's currently what it's
advertised as in their catalogue now
before that the um imi
version of it was also sold as i don't
be able to make this out
desert eagle
pistol
on the slide there so it went it
went from a sort of
branding variant of the jericho to the
desert eagle pistol to being rebranded
again as the baby eagle which
is what it's called i think what it's
called in the game
and there's a version of it in the game
that that actually does look like this
because this is a steel frame and the
reason it looks so different to what i'm
seeing on the screen here is that the
very the latest version of these pistols
have the polymer frame very very
long-winded way of saying the baby eagle
is a real thing now it is only a
branding thing because
this is a
pistol based on the czech
cz75 and the styling is a little
reminiscent of the desert eagle pistol
also made by imi hence someone had the
idea of branding it as a desert eagle
nine millimeter so in that sense it's a
baby eagle or baby deagle if you prefer
but it's not meaningfully a desert eagle
it's a standard browning uh dropping
barrel lock up it's much much smaller it
fires a normal pistol caliber it's it's
not no more a desert eagle than my ford
mondeo is
a mustang
not what i would expect to see or
remember seeing in payday 2 we have a
vintage firearm here this is the c96
mauser pistol nicknamed the broom handle
or broomstick here you don't need to
make it legally different guys it's only
a nickname i don't think well unless
someone's trademarked it anyway named
broomhandle because the pistol grip
vaguely looks like the top of a broom
handle it's an affectionate nickname
it's not nothing official this is a very
nice uh pre-war commercial variant from
our from our collection it's not the
oldest form by any means but it's early
enough that it's got really nicely blue
finish on it and that appears to be the
model that's being depicted in the game
except that it does have the classic c96
holster buttstock attached but then from
this point on it's different so
it has what i think is meant to be the
1917 trench carbine variant carbine
barrel and forend and it has the
detachable magazine this just has the
classic c96 floor plate and you load it
from the top but from
what i've seen we have got some variants
of all of these so let's see what the
gameplay brings us
slightly odd so this this version of the
gun anyway has the detachable magazine
but they're not using it they are
loading it from the top with stripper
clips charger clips whatever you want to
call them which you certainly can do
maybe they've only got one magazine for
this thing and that's why they're doing
that he's also holding it like a
conventional pistol which you definitely
can do um you can still shoulder it and
hold it with it with a two-handed grip
and that will work just fine for you but
the version that that we're seeing here
has the carbine fore end and you'd want
to hold it like a rifle for
three four points of contact depending
on how you're holding it i assume that's
just because the base model of the gun
in the game is still a pistol and so
it's still being fired as though it were
a pistol
the deagle the proper deagle not the
baby deagle it's a nice rendition i
think i didn't i didn't grab one because
we've covered the desert eagle quite
quite a bit on on this series but it's
nicely modelled i think uh the
proportions look to be correct and
they're not always the thing though that
catches my eye is the serial number i
think that's the serial number has been
kind of really badly gouged at which can
only be a reference to a criminal
firearm where serial numbers will
sometimes be removed in order to to make
the the weapon harder to trace i guess
if they are the ones who have procured
it they do not want the authorities
being able to to trace it back to where
they got it from
uh okay pause there did i just see a
tiny american flag did i see that i did
see that okay well
why not i suppose uh the desert eagle
despite the fact that
a lot of them were made in israel
is definitively an american invention
and an american pistol and it's about as
an american a gun as you can get and i
don't mean that disparagingly
it's just it's big it's bold it's
powerful it is
somehow fitting that there is a tiny
american flag on it it's just a shame
that there isn't a bald eagle somewhere
on it as well
they have really leaned into the
ridiculousness of the desert eagle here
with the the 10 inch barrel option in
the gunsmith which is there is a there
is a 10 inch barrel for for the desert
eagle that makes it look even crazier a
laser on the bottom a red dot sight on
the on the rail on the top i don't know
i think i'm i think i'm a
when this thing pops up i like to just
see it as is without all of the extra
stuff attached it would become
significantly less easy to use with all
of that on it there's also a nod toward
the relative sheer power of this thing
for a handgun with one of those helmets
going flying straight up in the air by
about 10 feet which is probably
something of an exaggeration but uh that
there is an awful lot of kinetic energy
transmitted by the 50 caliber
action express
round let's leave it to that
mp5 i'd be disappointed if this wasn't
in the game
mp5k a1
kind of it's got the butt plates with no
butt stock and it's the short receiver k
model but it does not have any barrel
protruding from from the front which is
odd you'd have to achieve that you'd
have to cut the barrel down and it does
not have a vertical grip now there are
civilian versions of the mp5k that don't
have a vertical grip there are
hand guards you can get that don't have
it there's clearly space to fit it and
i'm sure you do that in the gunsmith
interface at the moment we have them in
basically morpheus in matrix reloaded
trim only in that weirdly it had no they
just took the front handguards off
entirely which made them look really
weird
we've also got there the mp5 sd or sd2 i
guess it would be the basic design
hasn't changed since the 70s when this
was introduced very very visually
distinct even for an mp5 with the the
very large
circular profile hand guard there which
is necessary because of the suppressor
which comes all the way back to the
receiver sleeves over the barrel and the
barrel is ported so that those gases are
instantly expanding into the back of the
suppressor reducing
the pressure differential between the
gun and the outside world i always i
always describe it as letting the air
out of a balloon instead of popping the
balloon but it's highly effective even
by modern standards this is a you know
not not bang up to date by any means
although the suppressor has been updated
over the years it's still one of the
quietest suppressed firearms ever
created people say that all you hear is
the bolt reciprocating um there is a
little bit more of a pop than that but
to be quite honest the bolt is at least
as loud as that as the shooter you may
well be more aware of the mechanical
noise of the weapon
than the report
at this end so it is it's highly
effective still in limited use in
certain certain quarters i'd gather but
like most submachine guns it has been
replaced by suppressed rifle caliber
weapons or buy pistols as a secondary
weapon
right so having heard the payday 2
version of the gun i'd say it's about
right gain you know game sound effects
coming through speakers or headphones
it's it's going to be pretty subjective
relative to the other guns it's maybe a
little too loud because it's sort of
maybe maybe it sounds only half as quiet
as some of the other some of the other
weapons that i've heard that could be
the hardware that i'm listening to it on
but i'd rather have that if it is too
loud relatively i'd rather have that
than the qp sound that we're so used to
you know if
you're trying to achieve the right
effect
record live audio and and mix that up
it's always the best way to do it i
don't know if
these guys do that
oh lovely uh
gold-plated kalashnikov akm ish it's
it's pretty much a it's an akm receiver
yeah basically it's akm the barrel looks
a little slim and maybe a bit long it's
an akm with for some reason a grooved
wooden buttstock which is an ak-74 thing
and then
some sort of weird is that those
diamonds on the upper hand guard i
almost don't want to ask and then some
other weird dot things on the top cover
as well but it's a it's a pretty
reasonable akm it's only that it's
gold-plated which as we know is uh much
beloved of dictators and cartel members
and and people who like a lot of uh
bling on their
firearms
okay this says great fortune on the rear
of the top cover is that a reference to
something i don't know the rate of fire
is too slow as well as having fired and
seeing these fired and the rate is high
the rate of fire is higher than that
there is a a very popular misconception
that the akm had a reduced rate of fire
if it's at all reduced it's extremely
marginal um what what that was added to
the akm was a
device to get around the problem of bolt
bounce where when the bolt comes home it
bounces back and if the hammer strikes
at the wrong time the gun can stop and
they added a device to get around that
may or may not have slightly reduced the
rate of fire but if it did it was
extremely marginal and the manuals just
they both say about 600 rounds per
minute and this is
too slow for that someone's gonna get
out stopwatch and time it and prove me
wrong but it sounds too slow
auto revolver so called because it of
this version at least the act of firing
it revolves the cylinder and [ __ ] the
hammer rather than the finger or the
thumb cocking the hammer now i happen to
have
a different mataba model
here and this one
is just a double action trigger and very
different configuration as well this is
the mtr so a very different gun but from
the same italian company oh in case
anyone's wondering the weird reload of
the cylinder flipping vertically up out
of the frame is correct that is how the
model 6 metabo does operate this this
became famous in i think it's ghost in
the shell where it featured pretty
heavily and it's almost like the the
anime equivalent of the blade runner
blaster
okay now this i do remember from my
brief jaunt with payday 2 and it's the
colt m733
the 733 does vary so the version that's
in heat which is where this comes from
this game is a tribute to heat and so
they put the short-barreled
ar-15 from heat in it but they went with
a modernized form of it at least for the
stock rifle
so this
is the version that was used in heat
sufficiently vintage that it actually
has an aluminium sliding buttstock on it
rather than the polymer version 11.5
inch barrel well that's what you see in
the game a2 flash hider which means that
it has a solid bottom to the flash hider
and the open slots on the top designed
to prevent uh dust being kicked up uh
but it also gives a slight muzzle
compensating effect as well it's the set
it's the standard m16a2 type flash hider
but um ours has the
as i say the quite an old-fashioned butt
stock does have an a2 pistol grip but it
has the slim
carbine handguards that you see in heat
payday 2 gun has the thick m4 handguards
it has the
crane pattern stock with the sort of
almost they look like ventilation holes
that's not what they are on it that's
part it's polymer and it also has um a2
sights thicker chunkier bit here and
adjustment wheels for the for the sights
this m733 does not now that doesn't mean
that this is not an m7 33
because these were quite variable in the
furniture that was fitted in the upper
receivers that were fitted some of them
had
full-on a2 uppers with the bump for case
ejection and the adjustable rear sights
but this is closer to what's in that
classic movie although it does have
which the movie guns didn't an a2 style
burst lower receiver not automatic so
even this isn't quite like the movie and
it has an acog mounted in the carry
handle
which they didn't in the movie either
but i'm not gonna take it off just to
make it look more like the movie gun as
awesome as the movie is and as much as
this is that's why this is probably my
favorite version of
the sort of vintage ar-15
right yeah that's that's an unusual
gameplay feature there we've got tasers
much abused in media because no one ever
gets them right and i'm afraid this
game's no exception they well firstly
they either work what they don't so
the probes either contact or or able to
conduct steel skin or they're not so if
you're wearing body armor probe has very
little chance of contacting so you would
have no effect if the probes did lodge
correctly in your clothing and and stun
you you wouldn't just be slightly mildly
inconvenienced you would be
absolutely locked rigid and
on the floor in the great the game's
credit it doesn't have the screen go
black and you wake up for half an hour
later like in the movies because that's
not how tasers work either it should
completely incapacitate you for a few
seconds is how it should work and then
very likely with an after effect where
you're moving very sluggishly because
when all of your muscles lock up like
that i am told and i have seen it's
extremely tiring so there would be a way
to do tasers in a tactical shooter to be
fair payday 2 is not really a tactical
shooter kind of cool to see uh
less lethal weapons perhaps interesting
more than cool to see them depicted in a
video game
thank you very much for watching as
always if you'd like to support the work
that we do here at the royal armouries
you can hit the description and you'll
find links in there to ways that you can
donate or join up and become a member of
the royal armouries museum we also have
social media outlets that you can you
can look up and our own youtube channel
featuring yours truly so if you're
interested in that head over to our
channel otherwise we'll see you again
next week thanks again for watching
[Music]
you